the famous tommy hilfiger personally introduced him to
his new
partner he raised tommy
hilfiger he is a swiss
so jumps german and a few months ago
he let himself be persuaded by tommy
hilfiger to move to hugo boss as global
boss from the german
sleeping giant hugo  boss
to do with a large company the guy who
wants to do all this has experienced everything
it is hugo boss's hope is
called daniel grieder and is
now from metzingen and what
does metzingen have in common that knowledge of course hugo boss
and have i am and may be in the room
of  new bosses because daniel reader has
the company hello hello philipp has
n’t been there that long, a
six months, that’s exactly
what we still don’t see, so everyone who
hears it now has to look it up on everyone on instagram or linkedin,
daniel looks like you  introduces a
hugo boss boss
although he has traveled a long
way before e  s with about the topless
against now a bit where are
you from where i
wanted to say when i start
speaking we immediately where i come from of
course with my old german that
i speak here but i hope you
understand so i was originally
from the  switzerland actually
born in america some say yes i was born in
washington dc but it was
only a year ago i can't
remember and after a year
my parents moved my family to
switzerland and i'm still there in
schaffhausen am rhein today
roughly yes i grew up
exactly and then you were already
many decades behind you in fashion but
not so much now as a
designer but always
so sales and as a retailer that can
say yes i was
actually interested in fashion
maybe he has to explain why i'm actually
always in there my name is rita and
if you're in zurich then he has  your
house that means krieger that is a
luxurious
small
fashion house or luxurious you have the
partners that a small park rid us
but extremely high quality and it's
been around for many years and everyone
always thought you're the bikes you
're the one from the fashion house no me  I'm not
the plaintiff from the fashion house I'm
just greta and and somehow it's been
from the age of 14 people
have approached me is the warrior for
fashion
but somehow I was
fascinated by it and don't even have the
almost anymore with the  fashion and then
i thought it was
actually interesting because it's
constantly changing and i'm interested in things
in the world that are constantly being
redefined and i found that exciting
and then i got to work
a bit with fashion  I have that
I could imagine
later, then my sister had a
German friend who was also
in fashion
industry i sometimes
helped out in the shop in the summer he was a
retailer in factories then
i helped him out during the summer holidays
earning a bit of money that was
more fun and so i
actually got into the whole fashion industry and
then did the apprenticeship  in the world and and
that's where i got stuck somehow that
fascinates me and and the fashion industry
i have to say i just find it
exciting because it's always changing
i have a a funny story you
got to know didi mateschitz from red bull
and he has this
I said man you know it's a
nice business you only have this
rifle because the bikes never had to sell they
actually never went through stock and
can talk about this rifle he says
no that's a disaster you're nice
you can invent a new story every season
and I can
must talk about this is this can all the time is
much more difficult is so
always prefer a new the  ma but it's
okay that's right so i'm staying in
politics but how did it really start for
you you started out was that you really
imported
american brands into europe
, so to speak, or you
can say that a bit differently that
started i have  then
I had big plans to start my own
business. I did
n't want to work in
a company and that was already during
my studies. I said I want
to become self-
employed or I founded my
own agency and in this
agency I was of course
ideas  and set up my own
leather sales company
it was one of those times it was like this
black lamb nappa leather was always it was
that i imported from turkey
and then i had great
success there already during my studies what he did
on
22 that already  started and
i imported the black leather jackets
and thought well there has his paw
gmds  leonardo and now I have something the
reasons i can too and
designed a brennt you is max
premiere
is not that i don’t even remember anymore because
he simply market was called
premium service something was called the company
and the brand baumax loads that
was high-quality leather  and that's how i
actually started and then the
first company i
asked if i would take over the sales in switzerland
and austria was pepe jeans
and then i took it with me to the agency
and then came along
who didn't have one of their own  wanted to buy
donauland she is now getting a
huge break in the industry has become yes
and it should seem that i have
a friend who also joined the company
have kept building it up
together and at some point
this tommy hilfiger came and then the americans called
were said people
actually have her  called
because she was at the time my agency
was okay but that wasn't now  t that
the prime example or where we
now call an american brand
now say i
called them saw it
in america was this in the brand i want to
bring to europe then they said yes
we are already in europe we already have
so many
inquiries that's done
call the queue so there's no giving up that
easily and there were a few coincidences
because the investors who were at pepe jeans
were also investors at
hilfiger that was all it was lorenz
team with them
and then I did  had the contact
and then i said lorenz
important this and be that we
would like to help besides i need my
old towers he says you do you have
page in sun you have no idea about
this sport and so i don't
even know what that is  there isn't, of
course, I decided to take
a break
and it went back and
forth and then I said nope
we want to go to another agency,
we decided and so i have
now i won't
let it rest on me anymore and then i made
them a suggestion which they
couldn't refuse and
i said okay he doesn't believe it
then show me i'll do a year for free
i'll do the sales will be for help
if i do it well then i
won't get it badly on me then you can kick
me out we don't have to
pay anything and said i did it
for switzerland and even more so in  took over sales
as an agent and
apparently did a pretty good job
so that after a year they gave me
the contract and they were
kind enough to pay
and that wasn’t exclusive
or white and exclusive that was exclusive
and then it is  a
bit like now the big ticket if you
can bring the sun to europe in the right phase then of
course it will be i  somehow at the
time i only had switzerland austria and the
east they gave me and i
was only allowed to do five customers
in switzerland and five in austria and
ten in the east at the time because they wanted
to slowly build up sales not that
there were delivery problems  So
Germany should do 100 customers
not do the five customers that
was just distributed the contingent
and every six months we were allowed to take on five
new customers you can
imagine there was an endless demand
but that's how we have it
built up sustainably that's why
I say  I was the cornerstone why also
help you then also positioned so well
overall in the in europe and in the
end you did all of europe
that sounds further so my
agency now had this pepe jeans
of the tonal hilfiger that was
it  that became
the agency in switzerland and
suddenly one day de called me  r
then ceo of hilfiger europe and
says
are you sitting then i say yes yes i am in the
car hold the car and i have i
have a suggestion for you and say
yes okay he says you i actually
want to stream more for the music and
would like to ask you whether you are so hilfiger
europe is
why i have yes my agency has a
little swiss and and also does
anyone from the big countries say
no i want you okay i have to think about it
and because i am
self-employed the water there  when I
was 32 and then I thought about it
then I thought that
my friend who I also have in the business
has something you'll take over I'll
go to Amsterdam then say yes do
it and
said done there were a few
other difficulties in between
health of my partner
then stupidly just got seriously
ill and then i
canceled everything and said no i'm not going now
i'm staying and then ha  when i
get a call again they are happy to come
but i can't find just any partner but i'm
also looking for a new one, as i
said, i didn't expect it
and then they actually
waited half a year and
then i came and started
as ceo in amsterdam for europe and then
have  you with after two years or a year
two years they first had me
as seo i was then
after two years they were ceo europe
for me that was of course crazy for me
never thought how big his
business so europe helps you have to
imagine as  100 million sales or 200
or 500 so that's where I took over
was you there we were like in Europe we were
more up to 350 million and
I have to say that we have where
we started in an office that was
half the size eight people  sales europe
hilfiger eight people from here collection
from america and
that was really exciting and we
thought if someone was really great
on the road  we might make 100
million in europe then
within three years we made 350
million so it was crazy
and and now hilfiger is so
it went up so quickly we
are then five years later we
made a billion in sales alone  in
europe and then
1.5 and so on it's grown incredibly
i couldn't imagine
how it works and it worked
because so many
dealers wanted it too yes we
not only have that but we have also
expanded the collections  at first
we only started with men then we
took on women then we took
domiciles then we made children
made my shoes
accessories that was really a
build up because we have there I can’t even
dream of it being that big the broken one is
that big without that  ever thought and
then the congregations in the usa noticed there
was the guy and europe who broke the
egg  direction next they have
to go to the usa where yes that was then
yes that can so the head of europe back then
who betrays against he then took over
where i took over europe he took over
globally and then it
was somehow clear
that then  when it goes away
i'll actually take over
globally but i didn't give it
much thought so that it
actually came about that way and then
we also took the license for a calvin klein on top of
that we were then
sold to page and  that that was
an unbelievable are really from 0 at the
end
alone in europe together with calvin klein it
was a two and a half
billion business so that was
really so so big had missed actually but then that was only
europe and then we have new ones
strategy determined that he is hilfiger in
the end i left it
was just under five billion
hilfiger alone but the w  elt
you have yes and what yes also
responsible worldwide but yes what was achievable
77 years thought
women's sports help comes all the boys
that was of course great in the last
eight years and how much water in the
building help when you put everything together and
he's done with agencies  the dates were
21 years ago and the hilfiger company
no longer belongs to
tommy hilfiger himself but to
financial investors yes that was that
too so it’s another
story so at the beginning it was on the
stock exchange where i got to something on the
stock exchange  and when i came to
armstrong we had private equity and
four people bought the company
and then we had private
equity so we were a small part
had management and then
three four years later we had anti age for example
through global  company the global of
what you were already involved oh what okay
you then also lost a lot of entrepreneurial
weight that you actually have something
I had fun it was
actually somewhere in my heart I'm still
the entrepreneur today but I was
able to get involved and then I
managed the company anyway so
that was ours the tommy hilfiger
works yes of course he was also
there with the  he was in this team
where i used global
boss with tommy hilfiger there
was a bit more in the background
and me where i started
i fully integrated into the business again and
i wanted to keep with your background
to the outside and he became in
we have stock exchanges and we had a great working relationship.
he's him
too, so i say my best advice,
he didn't make the decision
, i actually
supported me more in all areas, from the
collection to
advertising campaigns to testimonials to
general that that was it  really a great
cooperation that has shaped me a
lot and that means
a very, very good one through friends  friends yes
okay and only now there was more than a
second where you noticed now it's over
here or now I can't
be anymore now we have absolutely teak
and or weigh how did it
happen that suddenly hubers for the clubs one
that was different that  was i have to say
i always ran the whole business, including
tommy hilfiger's global office,
we haven't been in america for a long time, we
brought it to europe, so we set up a
campus in amsterdam, that was
the ultimate in a campus and
that's why  I was never I didn't do the
business from America at all,
but from Europe worldwide
and
actually everything was wonderful and top
and it was about that I could then take the
next step but to
take over the ps that means
maybe the other brands too  say the
hollow ones behind yes exactly and I would have
had to go to America and
I didn't want to do that privately now for
private reasons  nd or also from
i wanted i was in america i
lived there when i was young
that was over for me i
wanted to stay in europe because
i like it and then i said
yes i will stay in my job and that
’s okay too  I'm happy and it
was successful and I do
n't want anything else is I'll stay where I
am and do it for the next
five, six, seven years
and then
the hugo boss people came to me and
told me we'd find what we could do
you can imagine that and at the beginning
they came twice the first time i
said no i'm not interested in the
bean and i'll stay and i'll also
go well and then go from tommy the
first time i refused but then
you can see them a second time  where i was a
bit open because you can
honestly say the company has always
accompanied me it was actually
direct competition and at the beginning you
just have to have the ultimate that was the
fir  where we orientated ourselves they
had everything in place they had the
right product they had the
right sales strategy they had the
right advertising that with ours it was
all there the brand was hot and
everyone wanted hugo boss and then
that's it  we were nothing with help at the
beginning and somehow things turned around
at some point
and we sort of gave them over the last eight
years then hugo boss agreed that
the field was handed over without a fight i never
understood it but i always knew that
there was extreme potential here  aus is in the
mark because the brand awareness is in the
twenties because everyone
had to wear it and hugo that was also strong
for the youngsters and i always
thought there is potential so the
brand is the facade as it is there where is
it for  boss hilfiger the most important
competitor you would say i think
at the beginning we weren't that serious about each other
so when i was still at
hilfiker they took us  didn't take it all that
seriously and then it turned skin on
but that for one of the is now
also today you look at it the most
after all so asked who is now
peer group or something that's already today
yes he is one of them we also have them
different collections so what we
have boss black we must have orange
again we have boss green that's more
honest and this boss orange that
's casual and you can compare that
with hilfiger and that boss black that's
him ralph lauren
armani burberry that's ours
competition at boss black and so in
any case i then somehow
i have people approached me
mazet that we are the
main shareholders indian family the
15 percent of boss really heard how
much 15 yes exactly and then i have
i  thought well they did
we met then i said yes
i can just do it i would be
tempted to bring this company
to where  she actually belonged i
was firmly convinced there is no reason
why google boss should be small
than hilfiger because actually
hilfiger is still boss orange so
actually boston should be even
bigger than hilfiger and so i said
yes come on in my last in
my last  I
'm not going to do it more relaxed for the next five years
and I think
I thought now I'll do that now
I'll do it now was I really feel like it
now and that's why I'm
okay understand you again then because it's
interesting you obviously have that
after the  maximum is striving so you had
the chance from hilfiger, which
at that time was already four billion five
billion many 2 billion yes to
changes to the even larger holding company
what the dimensions of the business
year were then
888 billion and that belongs
but is that to the company
belongs to the new style no that's lorenz rolle
out a long time before  r that we
then bought it covered with lead the
farmers as teenagers is a today
project i and company
pages
can stop it but that
would have been usa we didn't and then
you allowed yourself to be persuaded and in the
end it happened  usa
matching yes
[laughter]
summarizes that's true but and
you can also read there too as an
entrepreneur again so you know what they are
but you are also partly involved in
bosses here yes i invested
yes because after the dream job and also
entrepreneurial again  as
indirectly means when he has convinced himself
do nothing at all then only if he
teaches a good course and I somehow
now have three percent respect yes that is of the
order of magnitude that is one percent
or 201 half or
that's only
about
ok so don't know anything now  i
don't do much now but for the films as a
whole it's not like that so
huber's power struggles are like 39 percent are
already 35 million the i  it's a lot of
money but that's not the need
less well ok then you have to take
a year off because there's a non-
competition clause and until then I'm
at the start and what do you do now
to bring things forward so maybe you have to do
it again  go back and
say yes where they said you
really aren’t allowed to work for a year after
21 years i would of course have
expected them to say come on you did
a good job
you can of
course start at hugo boss tomorrow
but like the
americans said it won’t come  question we
insist on this
non-competition clause that i signed at the time because i thought it would stay until the end anyway bild krieger am then the challenge
of but that can't be and
then i have to do it for a
year now since you're away from that  window
or if you left the industry
then you don't know anything anymore and
then this corona came say now  e me
that was after the devastating so why
but wasn't that bad for
me this year break because i had a
lot of time to think about things a
bit where
i didn't have before the very first thing
was a little bit about my  to
take care of my sons you have to have a bit more time
with them and the second i
think i prepare myself excellently
for this job i could
talk to customers i couldn’t notify the company
i couldn’t read reports i couldn’t
look at the product that of course that was
optimal preparation
44 then  to start on the first six i
was also in america a lot and got to
know a new partner and
spent a lot of time there so a
wonderful year despite corona
experienced you and with a perfect
preparation for the job i am now
and what can i say now what  in
the first course setting you
do that you came in here you
can also read about it all h  But I said
okay now you're moving forward and
that was also a lot of
expectations the stock price
had already risen when it was clear it was going to
happen yes then somehow
the share jumped really noticeably
and then you immediately at the beginning
so  came in it said okay so and
so it starts here immediately presented a
program tell me what are the two
three main ideas that are now going on
so the city was the most important
thing i actually had to that was clear to
me i had to set up a strategy where
everyone understands exactly where we are and
where we want to go and
stole a brief word about what was
going on yes that is that it was like that when i
was always convinced and am
convinced that the potential is much
higher than what is now but
you have to define it  how do you get there
and then of course i had
enough time
to set the course how do you get
there and those are so easy
carefree important  gene building blocks where you have to
be clear that sounds the first
maybe quite normal have to put the customer
in the foreground but not because
apart from the end consumer and we do
n’t just want to have an end consumer
but we want to
win over the failures so that
’s very important today  now in the fashion
industry and in every brand
a brand has to bind the end consumer
and you can only do that
if you make the brand relevant if you
make it relevant, so today you can be a heritage
brand or have a harry table
that no longer counts today  So
some of the best brands are
no longer worth anything today because they weren't
reactivated and that's why it's very
important that we make the ones
that burn sexy again or so popular that
the end consumer is removed from them
again because it used to be him - it has many
boxing fans  given because I used to work
for hugo boss myself, kant
sometimes gave me, however
, has  back then by hugo van dijck maja that
or earlier you
finished your studies your first job you have hugo well
that that the first thing we
create know what you win back these
these cases end consumers
and then we have
different peters the first  is
booster brennt that means we have to make
brennt relevant again and that
's where we started by
clearly changing the logo, you'll
see in
January what it
indians are like
that
actually fits a lot of these names hugo
and
shot then we have the ones that
exist the brand hugo boss is the
platform we take care of the platform hugo
boss and on this platform has two
brands one post for the millennium
and the other is hugo for  den set there
are two brands on this hugo boss
platform that's let's say booster
burnt that's the most important thing
the second  is product is king so you
can also work in any industry if the
product is not right if you do not have a
product that has the best price
performance and also tells the story then
you only have a short-term chance of being
successful and we have a lot going on
now  product really invests
so also invests the product made
better a better price performance
we also put grimms in because it is
like that even
if you open the article it also looks nicer on the
inside so we
actually upgraded the product and
if you do that you  do you also have much
better sales but that means in the
fashion sector the product has
become more important sounds
surprising when you think it's
as much as the marca in the end we have
good shirts or even pullover jeans
there are those that are similar
in terms of quality with many brands but it
's about which brands wear but you
say it's not like that but
meanwhile  Has the product become more
relevant again? A
lot of memories. The product must also be relevant again.
Sustainability is also part of it. The church said
that the price is right. But
now, for
years, the
weather was fine. It's nice weather, but I have no
idea what that means for the market  is now
you have to imagine how you
feel you feel good because the weather
is good but if there is a small one now
the police will turn it off we will
certainly make it even
better product better and then you
still go to the manufacturers and say
okay  now other other substances
nutrients of the substances we also have to
redefine the suit now you know
about these suits that's just
not like that there's ok fast tracing that
's for weddings you have a normal
suit
and you used to go to work in
a suit  that's actually
uncomfortable or we don't
believe that the suits the time of the
suits  t is over but
it will only be redefined then how
is it more performance driven the
motto resistant angle free that is
a suit where you feel completely comfortable
where you can
also get on the plane sonja get off that is perfect
so that’s for  example
something like that I had myself back then that is
totally fit that has
no folds drink free that is
actually an adidas adidas suit made
as taylor so these are fabrics
from sports therefore performance suits
and we totally believe that is the one
with  the wreath cyclist mountaineering with the trans he can go to bed with him i
can
go to bed with him you can too
those were which role donated
designers i mean sometimes it's the
time when a lot of designers
virgin upload such people that
have always changed the world a lot
does the game play a role for
you because you don't see designers
that way that you now
make them yourselves purely according to desi  gn
so criticism
creativity is of course extremely important even with a suit like this
and he has to 17 he has to
keep coming up with something new
now is a double row and
then tomorrow it will be another row
let's come up with something again
so that you can be new again  but the purchase has to be
creative is very important and that is what
addressed the creativity of the design
and that has also developed in the past
they used to draw on a white sheet of
paper today we are
just doing that digitally
you can always design a part digitally
but that doesn’t mean that you’re no longer
creative you’re simply
able to design faster and better and
today everything is more fast-moving that means
i used to have to for a suit like
that i had maybe three months until i got
the right one  cut had
chosen the right fabric, the right color, the
right buttons heykants that's basically
inn  within hours with a
modular digital system where you can do
that
but the creativity
you only need and you brought in new
people or make sure that the
same people are us we
actually tried to
retrain the existing people to digital
world that you were right in the middle of it and of
course we brought in noah from the
outside, so at that time we already took a few
people in addition but in the whole
company that he started the nice week
there are so many dollar
young dynamic people here who also have good
training  they have the unbelievable
experience they are hungry
to do something new and i have to say
that was just in the last few years
look at the campus we use
everything else is there but it was little
used and that's in for me again
a children's shop from game to game
were job how easy it is everything because
you just have to activate it you have to
dust it off you  you have
to need it again it's a great
situation usually not we do
n't have to reinvent ourselves it's because we just have
to reactivate it and all these
classic what do you have these these
fashion rules of the game i now even as
fashion also one to watch you
have to  make a collaboration then you have to
work with influenza all that you have to do like keep it
short that makes it
natural now that it is also part of the
game of history in today's
fashion industry
you have to make collaborations you are the testimonials rating
that you can't just do that just a
collection  make sell and
that's it no that's the story telling
the colleagues from api mio you
know
market research company
no longer clung to star data in which you
may be involved to a small
extent where the ceo and founder of the
jonathan chorfest was in the podcast a few months ago
so  a company from our babbel
asked me welc  he was so
funny at the moment very often higher say
like that and we immediately realized okay the
central and
nft stage in so themes obedient regularly
but it's just my little bubble on
linkedin my feed on instagram in
my environment something like this keeps popping
up that helps  abdi's project
because they now
want to find out for themselves how representative
is what one
perceives and therefore ask 1000 people
and then just really representative to create
the so-called up in uk train report for
which there is now the next one
for  the most diverse areas for
fashion for food for automotive
and then you experience what is really relevant to
hals in the respective areas
who wants to take a look
the first report goes live on march 16
you can already register for the download
under abt in your point comes
train
the first collaboration is bigger was
the second was with russell it is the
first relevant to  that was the shave
athletic was a super success i
think that was the first time i was told
the the industry quickly or the end
consumer because everyone
only expects suits from us this
russell athletic
cooperation is coming a very long-
established tradition year but
of course still boys
something for the boys what that is
then we did the fashion
show in milano
which pushed social media so with tik
tok they did the first event with tik tok in the
fashion area too
and we created a world where to
first time from the appearance with the
whole social media world with the
blogger something will happen with the nfc and
the first led five jackets of the nfa who put in
there
so there have already been new things that
nobody expected from hugo boss
but also, of course, the
collection, the product, the completely
surprising thing, now that's because
let me tell you, we're back
on stage now  e but you yourself are the
one who says okay we
have to do something with russell as lantiq now
or let's say you're looking for
such a cooperation or people are coming
and they suggest something and
or do that - sequence independently of
you you even have  athletic was
already there and i
embellished it even more and that is actually the
process based on both
people come with suggestions i come with
suggestions there there you hear people
sitting there saying okay from the
ancestors what what  would probably be best
if it works that way in everyone who can
bring suggestions and is with
nfc one is also just like that the thing
somehow came that so you also
said man that would be but now what have
I observed that I would  I
wish five my company or yes that's
the way we have we have
something what can we do now
to simply surprise people this
event is this unexpected
and it i  st think about what
you can do there and then a
gift is yes try this time
wonderful idea but I have
done something else do you know
tapestry of the dictatorship of the 110 million who knows
this this hand mobility had to
know the madness and have it
we was brought of course
i would say in this chip set
generation that is a hero and that is
that is a real post i will
add right away why snack boss the construction a
year and a half ago he couldn't even
pay for the apartment and he was
an italian
the one who really has no idea
what to do with life then
he also had tik tok had these these hands
is yes he always did something so you always do something that
is too complicated he
then repeats it and says why does it
is very complicated it can  but being so
easy to end always made
this and that's at the end we
instead because designer after the fashion
show someone comes designer v  on
hayek klatscht we got the
mobile out and he just does
it that was of course that was
groundbreaking and that has crazy ones
but you can't get them from anyone in the
area or I got them from my
parents I
also put something on the table  is
with him that means you have seen and appreciated more and more deeply
that means you
are really he was really so
intense everything at tecdoc you look at the encores
yourself that is happening right now
and so I'm not active right now so I'm
community so any break  to
do but i observe and that
's the same with the smallest
employee story i think
you have to know when you run a fashion company and here you have to know what he
can't just say yes that
's treason there i am  no longer in it
otherwise otherwise you shouldn't actually
be I think you have to get it with
it then you believe in the
metal market  se on metal exchanges or let's see
you're absolutely yes yes because that
's actually quite simple if you that
's a the fish world so that
's actually a dream world or and I
think if so when I was
little I also have in one  dream world i
played i put my
racetracks together and
thought im here and have my
own formula 1 what i made my world
easy and now you
don't do it for yourself anymore you
do it digitally and i
definitely think so  that everyone
likes to do that that is a world where
it will not be my world
but i am convinced that we the new
generation will create a new world where
you can actually dream and not
only that but that will also be a
business and  in the future there will
be online business offline
business and there is a meter wide world
that will be one business but not
one but several w  probably or
and another one of a meter what we
then everything different will give several in
any case for which which plates
these fts made who are the
platform is but we made a respect
challenge where you then
grow your where you these we there  we had been able to
win in there and that was the
first boost that we actually gave
in this world where
nobody used to deal with bus
but i think
you can't just ignore that
but you have to use it and
catch up  and you have to get the know-how
whether it's from new people or
whether it's from somewhere you have to look at
it new work some results
so he was basically waiting for you
or say no say
everything ok boss nice but no
so you see, now he thinks every
or many brands, especially in the
luxury sector, go jan these meters per 1
everyone experiments experiments a
bit  n we too have
experimented with it but we don't
just want to take it out of the boiler that series
is starting a business there I think
so we are in contact
with people or agencies who come
from outside and when I get the
numbers we know what  they've
gotta be talking about a person that's
insane the whole business
is always my 200 billion in
business methodology and that has
potential in the next five years to go
to 82 billion the entire business
and there has to be  you can already say that
is that you can be sure really
with the individual elements tokens
nfc to trade
and sell and if that's
still a percent of it, it's
incredible what kind of potential there is
and that's why I think  that
we have to deal with it four times
and testimonials are there
already something new or i think i
said new ones are coming in january
yes well we over the years i
said the new campaign is coming
out we also came up with something i have to fall
back on that for a moment so
we said to ourselves we will do
the booster burns that means we also
have or will also redefine hugo
it goes like this so what is a
bus from today's world moments says
he is in boston celtics is one from
a company patria and
[music
] we want to completely redefine it
today should be a bus that
stands for what that can move what that
does something good regardless of whether you're a man or a woman
bios so you're also a bus or if
you tell your story you
founded your company it
's worked out
several times the sale that's a boss you
have that is a fund
& beyond boss so we'll have that in
selected the bonus they are real
buses and we will also use them
that is now the boss and then hugo is the
younger version so we say that it is
more rebellious these are the people who d  they
don't follow trends these are people who
develop trends and that tells me you
go go go go your way
and that's that's almost a completely
new language that we're staging and and
that's precisely tailored to
millenniums with their bosses because everyone
becomes  who likes to think is to be a bus
but just a modern post
and we also tailored the campaign to that
and we have
in
jossa the boxer that we already have that's
when you see how the carrera
opened future the redbook
knew but you'll see  so that
we then we also have a
south korean lee minho spirits he has full of
millions of raffles giant star there
then we prefer kendall
jenner here so very big after not very
big
cable next to this one with 110 honest
schmidt or between us so our
olympics  participant in athletics almost
because i play
crazy then matteo gritti tennis
player 7 on the world
of ideas
are so that's ten tests  imonials
where i define everyone from actually
as 1 1 boss and people who
have achieved something and also don't fit the brand
or rather our family and
our philosophy and our
values so hotline boxer tenni
player athlete then looked for personalities in music and
that's in the
bus and then we have in the hugo area
what he major i don't know if you know the
names but the big matthew girls
his job package that's more of a dance
music scene that takes place there and
he actually has to know a lot of them
and maybe they have now  think
maybe one or two testimonials were chosen for the bus to
start with teeth so we almost got
involved ourselves or can you also make 100
suggestions did you have that
we have that we have the team we are
here and i have everyone there  laid down and
and that's a funny
story they made me a few
suggestions and there you are
ok there the first ones  i have it i
don't think i'm allowed to have it yet
i would like someone where people say oh
holy [ __ ] and now internet and i
feel holy [ __ ]
[laughter]
computer trade
lane assist holy [ __ ] that's
unbelievable and that the hallesche band
and they have it  we also addressed everyone
we put everything on the table
out out out but always the wars
then that would be amazing why
should they come to us so make the
impossible possible and that's
canceled somehow didn't want to take part either
that turned out to be two  had it there
that isn't coming yet didn't
want to but you have to honestly say
it can't get much better
absolutely so luck and that's like
an expensive list or was it anyway
now that's what I thought too but
how do we do that  the idea
especially when you when you come with beer
and bristles said you can you the boss
you can you are real boss is
that they liked that  you
liked the story and and and the story
we tell that is when i show you the
film who maybe later i can
show you that it really
gives you goosebumps
but i now have a few names that i associate
with boss they are so let's
say mats hummels  is also for
me he is still yes yes then I
totally crass recently I'm a big
basketball fan I saw there
were players in kate thompson he's
called from the golden state warriors who
could play all alone and have
everything very  had a lot of effort but that
you turn post she is he exactly that
was really big the short so it
follows because the comeback lost after two
years so that mostly
master candidate to a legend and on
a big box because I was surprised
that is also from the  list social or
there we still have it the
list is still so long but we
can't all play together but
we'll give you the chance to speak  that also
this sponsoring where we where we
are dealing with
which people do we want to spit who
is behind it it's not just about
the best but it's about the one
who can say something i
always have to i keep coming back to
the formula 1 if you take it now in lewis
hamilton or
there has so many great drivers but who
is a real boss in formula 1
see and there are now corporations of
the max dusty there are also
great performances but
we are looking for people  who are not only
models or musicians but also have to do something
else now lewis
hamilton there are the best drivers
but I like more that he stands for what
can be on our list
you choose earlier is more mobile and
but these are the people where we are
identify us because he not only stands for the
best formula 1 break and can
even make collections really
himself and he also stands for the whole
story with blacklight  it also stands
for something and the bad when you
read people interviewed like this then you also talk
more often that one topic is now data
and so to speak all this I think
even ki you use your mouth as
terms that now also rely on what
is meant by that what are you doing there
so the the the whole world the
all the data that's the world he's
just a data leak and i think
data will play a very important
role in the future but what happens
many companies do you collect the data
everyone said we collect  data we
collect data flowed with the data yes
they we will analyze the data from the
expand it great
and then comes the third thing that is
crucial he and what does how
integrated the data now yes i give them
to my people say what do they
do then  then you pay and
most say 90 percent don't know
what to do with it anymore and we do
the first two years but we
now have one with a company e.g
together we founded a bachelor camp
there are some of the people who are the
porto in portugal
that will be a camp with 300 people who
do nothing else but
collect data there organize data analysis but
now the most important thing is
also the data so
picked and so that we whole  clear, especially since
55 data can be integrated into the business every day
, so a
consumer would be analyzed, where
he is, what he buys, how he powers, etc.
and we will integrate that into the business,
what works, what doesn't, and
we'll do that together with one  company called
matt is with them we
founded this temple and to be
honest,
dates without dates in the future you
can hardly control any business anymore than
we will  Formula 1
and when you see what's actually
happening behind Formula 1 then it's
actually mainly peppered with data
hey  eats there is the car there is the
driver and the rest is all data and
there is data that's yes at mercedes it's
engineers from the 80s who do nothing
but
collect data data evaluate data leads the
existing race the data is
analyzed immediately and our  author
recorded but also for the next
races and the race in a year and
then testing is done then you get a
feel for what is being tested then i
saw that i thought to myself if we were
to do all this data because with you in the
fashion industry too
better evaluate better use and
also test before you go out then I
'm much better positioned and that
's what we are but collection
selection on the bald compilation of
collections about customers about
when exactly is bought in the shops
which weather and so on and so  from
what you what price ranges january in
february/march there you can
analyze endlessly but that can also be too much
be a mere mortal
don't even know what to do with it but
then maybe it's okay to say okay in
january more expensive things
are bought then i was just
corresponding to january also more
expensive offers and in the
way cheap things aren't bought at the end of the month
maybe he could  then
inevitably says yes then it’s even cheaper
that you have dynamic pricing plays a very
big role right now in
online business you can of course
change it almost every day and adapt the
offer to it and that’s
when you collect this data more and more
each  year we're going to be better
you're going to be intelligent you'll be better you'd be
better
too can have some of it well that
's where I'm really strong rock tech data is
in us talk show you're different so wanted
all the data and also talk about online again
what should  this china this
chinese
super retailer superbrand what this that
is growing really fast what  what we do
is also what you observe say clearly
that those who do it that exactly
what they do they build on
data that is nothing more than just
data played facts that then implement
in the product test of course low prices
yes of course we want that  don't
join in but that that is that that
is the form we're doing it now in
a room in the same price range but that's
the same as him as he used to be
let me tell you where the collections were
made they just
said yes me  believe in that and i
believe in this and i
have to have that today will be
tough is now that are facts to
say we
probably have so many hands so many
jackets in this price range in these
these qualities for next season and january  in short that
's my left
to chance that's already the case with luxury brands
as if you know you know it
would be prada or gucci or or where
they  there done so i went
before that yes everyone is dealing
with this topic i would say but i
don't think anyone
in our industry is so advanced that they
orientate themselves accordingly
and that's a big one i would say
one  competitive advantage that we have
because we have already implemented it
so we
started this campus construction six months ago with this company
why do we do it together with a
company we would do it alone
I would lose far too much
time that is  yes also in porto has the
right
ones that they are specialists who don't do anything
else that's that's honest
work or they even work for
us that has to say to me
they have taken over exclusively now or but they
have so we have with the
intention deal that we  the company that
makes the setup, they make all the
people buy back 25 percent
of this company every year, that means the
fü  nf years then we own the company
then we have the know-how then
we have then then then it works so
then we don’t have to we wouldn’t have a
chance to
build up a bit next to what we do otherwise
so you probably wo
n’t even become a developer  just got here after
mezingen and
that he also yes that we
ask another question namely if you
now the boss is trying
to invent something really new to do something completely different which
i now assume that certain
fashion brands are no longer
that good  maybe it
only works because it's a new design or a
new look because the whole idea is
completely different there are these sneakers
brand dacia we
said they make vegan sneakers at the beginning
i understood that i was okay with that what's that
supposed to be  now i don't care so
i knew straight away that there were
more vegan schools but he didn't
really get it and then he was ir  at some point
because you were in there and they then developed
a huge story because they had
a completely new idea for us for
shoes so previously no one
talked about shoes should be vegan
they invented that and they
helped a lot also good design and stuff like that
but  they were able to differentiate themselves with
a completely new level,
i.e. veganism in shoes and there is
no need to say something like that to the boss
, okay, I have to search again or
find something that is even bigger than now
other testimonials other other look
other brand what else  once addressed a new
level like that has something with
this started with mountain stages so
you also go into a chapter for that
it’s another hour
that
I’ll say that the company is therefore a
good idea the idea is not that new so
I already have  at hilfiger shoes are made of
apples so that's fine
i think but that's the great
idea from this company is  t okay
they do the numbers in the shoe
and what do you do afterwards that do
two or three jobs what do they
do afterwards because this idea is then
often adopted by lifestyle brands,
so we are also extremely
concerned with sustainability and so on we
have, for example, in the great, so
then you can fully utilize that it
is a brand or that is a
story that you then also have to
sell in terms of marketing, but
many new products
will come in this direction, but I would like to address something completely
different, that’s just it  just
the sustainability now monument in
our textile in the textile industry
what we the problem is that we still have too much
waste 90 still all of us
we are all no saints in that
area we have to improve
and for me that is real sustainability
there goes  now it's not just about les
card but the problem is that we
generate too much waste and how can
we do that ver  connection in that we have
more data to know what
we actually sell or what we
actually need the better data we
have, the more precisely we can
produce, so we
actually produced less waste it's
important that every company
actually does that too  so set up what everyone
produces less waste now it goes
even further what is the problem we
have in the textile industry have
let me say 10 15 percent of the products
consists of wool another 30 percent
consists of cotton and 60 percent
consists of polyester so and there is  the
core problem what is the problem what is
what is polyester is plastic and where
does it end when you wear your sweater west where
where does it end everywhere it ends in the water
so if we continue as we have been doing
up until now then is
2050 are more
are more plastic  in the waters as
fish and that is a core problem that
we have to solve and to solve this problem
we have to  find an alternative to
polyester which is what we
are researching right now and are
pretty close to a possible new
fiber that we can use instead of
polyester there you can do that you can make that out of
mushrooms else make any of
the products that are here
so that's that is that  fact and if
so, if the breakthrough of the
textile industry firstly produces less waste
by analyzing the business
better and finding an alternative
to polyester, then the industry has
done something sustainable here
and we owe it to the planet because i
always say a planet no fashion
sustainability  is a
big topic for you so closer than you
somehow perceive with all the hype about drops and
tests but you do
n't put it forward because that
's not enough we are not
yet are not enough i
always say we can  not
perfect overnight but we want to
get better every day  and we are
constantly researching we are also working with other
companies it is our turn
to find new ways to make this
industry more sustainable and if
we succeed then we would not only like to
say that for our brand but
then i will be happy if the whole
industry that is really in front of the volt at
the be innovative and say
okay we might be able
to replace polyester as hugo boss yes what he would be then
worldwide and huge thing that
would be that would be above the current stock market price
there have to be persuaded that
should  yes that's that the riders there
i have now it's really about becoming
really sustainable and sometimes
it's with sustainability there
are these we're actually only
sustainable four times we're only two
in this dow jones index about
sustainability  we're doing a
good job, but i
'm not satisfied with that.
we haven't figured out the core problem in the industry yet
elesen i'm very committed to that and i
also work with a team
of us with
outside companies to find a
whoever new opportunity here ok
ok and how relevant is something like this
compared to the hard facts
i.e. questions about distribution and yes logistics
ask what's playing that goes a
long way, of course, but of course it has to be this
big story that we have, so how
do we want to double the turnover there
you have, of course, the whole
thing, the platform under the back office
also has to participate, of course, you need the
warehouse you need  you need now
stands still at the moment there is of course
a problem and deliveries and
transport difficulties and that's how it was
, of course everything has to go hand in hand
unfortunately you can't just play on the
beautiful things, but of
course there's also a lot behind it
to achieve these numbers  and after the
meal we reach this number so that we can
also do it
. an indication of a boost  rat sat company
here from hamburg from the leaves
have not heard but should hear the talk
is from
99 why in hamburg good morning and
because everyone is doing it but here
it really fits it's about a chat
service in the end it's about website
traffic better  to convert and
keep best integrated on do not
comment landing pages on website
forms are not filled out and
all about it to shafiq acquired with great effort
which then threatens to break away
it helps a jackpot and so that
the climate is washable of course on the
basis of you can use the tool too
connect to senders to hotspot to others
who use exactly what a
jackpot can help in marketing to me
there is even a seminar by
my colleagues under nine points so
main.de mr there is also a
free trial version by the way to see how they
do it  colleagues can help you the
pattburg padborg pioneers here from hama
a term i thought you meant
for d  i also have a meaning the industry has
many slaves is director
consumer the chick is that also part of
your future playbook to say we
have to get closer to the consumers
themselves and also definitely at the end
marks that a few years ago
we clearly started thinking like this the stock market price
a corresponding one went up from nike everyone thought
it was good but there were also some pretty
tough moments but sometimes you have to go to
dealers that you have been
supplying for decades because they say you ca
n’t get any more goods we want to cut down
we only want to sell directly is
that at  you topic too
so I'm
standing a little bit behind because I
don't think it's just this
business but or just one or the
other but we're talking
about not appearing so we also want to
set up our distribution channel
what does that mean  that means
it doesn't really matter where the end
consumer buys our brand, the main thing is to buy it if it
's online  ne is offline doesn't
matter whether it's in our shop kraft or
at breuninger or like kadewe or
wherever or in a boutique
or in the posted com or in
another dot com doesn't matter we
i think that the whole representative has to be
summarized  will be in omniture and
partly that's the director's consumption
and that's also right but not only
i don't think one thing excludes the
other so we'll use all channels
100 percent don't just
concentrate on one say yes i'm
not sure anymore we want  working very closely and well with the retail trade
there are
hundreds of thousands of our own shops
100 yes we have 700 of our own shops
but as I said that’s only
part of it but of course we do it with
our customers all the
departments do that yes there they are
partners  we couldn't be without them
and they can't be the union,
so I have and and
that's why the dot c  om is
reading online and offline and in the future
that's one of the best things because it plays a role,
so distribution isn't just one thing
the other, that's why I distance myself from
yes, we only
make beetles,
we also keep the b-to-b
upright because i believe that things
have been shifting for 15 years
said yes retail is ready everything can only
be done online 8 that's over these
are statements that will
never catch on i think it's the
balance between everything including your
countries  I mean shops are also
expensive and then you have 700 pieces
even said somehow worldwide
it is further planned to do them all in such a
way that fear important
parts of the city in any case you also have to
redefine the shop how beautiful
will the suit be
redefining it's not just
about you making square meters of sales
but you need has a
shop to show emotions was considered once
was  to now take the car companies all
sudden shivers frames of the
city or the estonian to trade
car dealers outside on the green
field and tills it has the emotions
and where better to play that
than in the shop in the city and that's
why we will play our shops on more
we will bring in your one customer
why man journey is not the
german market where you
will basically be approached before the store or
we know who you are you come into the
store they don’t just ask
how can i help you but how
do you walk  and in which world do you want to
go today it is in the casual world
but is that in the
suit world or if the sports world we
will put is a completely different aspect
we will of course make coffee is
we will
make lounges we will
build up a digital network but that too  where you can
dress you right size
so we're going to play the store from
scratch where it's not about that  just about
but in motion square meters or
news that means it's also important
to train people that's a
pick up in january and enthusiasm for
the brand and whether they then
go out of the store and buy online or buy from a
neighbor ours are doing that
speaks currently  a role okay okay and
summer the website or the online
shop
there one hears actually wanted something else
because now bought it because it's
best for you the strongest that
somehow touch it plays a big role
i thought online trading will be here with
us  in the next five years
we said that will and that will
make up 30 percent that will be for sure what is
today but this 18 so there is still
something moderate that can be yes but i will
say that as i said i am not
a fan of each other but  it
will all play together in the future but the
online shop i say it is the biggest
flagship store shop design has to go up the
hill more now parente week  n have also
set it up again
redefine also
bring in more emotions and not only here is an
article that you can buy but that
is also brought up to
date where it is also an experience to
shop online also had drops
and stuff like that yes yes yes  that's very
important there too you always had to you can't just
bring two collections a year you
have to have different drops we have the
clearly defined you have to have
collections have to bring the drops so that
you are more relevant the business you
might do with the basics but you have to
keep doing it  create a surprise
just the said news per
square meter or surprise and
program with that's what counts
the bryant remains relevant and that
means the whole focus is
already strongly on the now younger target group
and what belongs also drops what
wants to do in the shops  collaborations
testimonials isn't too so the
generation about
45 50 maybe 60  yes they also have super
purchasing power have classic boss brand
awareness and that you could also
earn a lot of money yes
logically that doesn’t mean that we
cost the uae
we want to take the hall with us but we also want to
win over younger customers  and i always say it
doesn't matter we're still made
of paper it's the skin
you feel in your heart & long has i
always say and it's that everyone we pick
up but jobs had to define whether the
brand appeals whether you're selling boss  also to
amazon, for example, or via well yes,
but we say
we try to sell there in a very
limited way, so not via
the price but actually moreover
via the experience, so we also want to bring
our own shop into it, so
that if you go to amazon rain it is
for example at zalando then you
go into the box world and not
somehow here has an article and
then you get 20 p. from us  per cent
cheaper that probably not anymore
we don't want to get involved in the price war
but we want to bring a product
onto the market that one where you are
sure you have a good price-
performance ratio because I think that's
what ensures the most in the long term
that that  the brand also
works for the currently made
suits read ten percent of their users
do you really think there is a
lot about suits also sustainable to the
claim it was kind of a
pandemic anyway then suits weren’t
that much of a topic
do you think that future generations will be
just the same suit buyers
if we define the suit in such a way that it
lives off extremists these these gadgets
the performance is moderate i think
so what you eat you now have a
jacket yes you can also take the jacket
out but i am not many men
who want
one  wear a blazer to put the stuff in
somewhere that i
always say the price for the man what the
tas  che is for women and that's why
i think the suits wo
n't be over but you will wear more cash world
you can wear a place and
with jeans or with flex
or whatever
there i'm good that will continue ok
and  about yourself because my feeling
is or what you are doing now you also give
the market a face yourself
actually like that was already
hilfiger and that of hilfiger and
how successful fashion brands live
from the faces behind them so that
they are often named  also my
observation is like the brands rewe so
additional channels used to be or
germany stated that not all
people you know some of them too
or mr joop and so now my feeling
that if you follow the whole
story now you are suddenly hugo
boss  that's also somehow appropriate
i also think it's intended by you i think
that's what we have
to do i have to do that now i have to give the
brand a face  t give i think that
people like to see that
so i really liked that tommy because
he was the face and i could do
the business in the background
i like the version i have to say
but now
you have no other hugo boss
and thats me  but now i didn't
push it in any way but
wanted it i'm just
a bit more involved in this
area now, which i think is totally
important that it's simply authentic
and because i'm doing it because i
'm holding or also  the whole
strategy had
to be explained all the time and
people wanted to know where is the power going
now and who else is going to tell
if nothing isn't told and that's why
i've gotten a little
more attention now
and it's always been like that when you look at each other
now  you can see it immediately from the
price and that's
not how it was
with you  nd very i'm sure
small would you can trace me back to 14
14 years i
actually still have the same style
maybe i wore a little
less blazer but still
the same colors and even today that
's that's me that's me  at
the minister
walked around when i changed the brand here of course
but but that's my style
and that's me
what role does it play if china is
actually like that from a
time out perspective somehow if
luxury brands and that's part of it
also want to grow then it's okay  everything about
china or no that's great yes
you used to have companies or many brand
companies define their
growth strategies then that means okay we
will grow online we will
grow in china that's exactly what we want
but that's great we don't
just have them  opportunity only to grow
but we really have the
opportunity to grow in america in europe and in china
w  because we design the brand in front of seven lifestyle brands with much more
technology than just suits, and that means
we can
battle the whole lifestyle version in the women's and men's areas
, then let me say,
and gentlemen, that's why we have the opportunity to grow in
america, in europe and in china
what we don't need anymore and
there are also the same clothes so yeah
the feeling that you have to we have a
global collection which we of course
also adapt partly for the
local markets but we don't do
that so that you have one in that area
then we have in  sales we say yes
we can do most of the
grown that we can too but
we can also grow in the wholesale area
because that was a bit
neglected but we can also grow in the retail
area because
there are still so many opportunities for new
countries think pop  up stores or in
china but then also to china anywhere in the
world that's also the nice thing we
can not only in d  it's growing in this
area but everywhere that
's great and why do you think it was
n't done last year
? it would be almost
so easy
for me that the child would now that i can't say why not
but somehow it wasn't me last
year i did  so difficult because of but
before
that i don't know i did
n't quite understand the strategy what was
before but it doesn't matter you do
n't have to look back you have to look ahead
and i just see
what we have the opportunity
to grow with the band  now also what i
said with boss orange and boss
green quite a few but in the channels and
in the regions we have the virtuoso
in jena where you look we have the
opportunity to grow and i have to
say that it's a lot of fun that's
why i have to  don't sit here and say yes,
we can only grow in china and even more
digitally online, we can
grow in all areas that's the
whole potential  find great about this brand
what is actually the product
that sells the most in the end so
if you look at everything it is when you have
the t shirt or a white shirt or
jacket or so with us it
will probably be a shirt
pullover but that is  a good question because
then i have to go back a bit
there are these product groups now
let me say suits
are probably the market leaders
worldwide we are probably one of
the big suit suppliers because there are
but we also want in the
jackets  auto wise we want to
strengthen the product group but also in the
pants in the hands in the pullover
we still have just as much
potential again we will have these
product groups of suits that you
really played and prioritized and
we are exactly implementing that and the
nice thing  is conceivable for ladies and for gentlemen
the ladies actually grab
more second from the gentleman and we are
actually until now  t is more of a
men's brand, so this whole
area of women, which now makes
up 100 million in the entire compa
y, we can quadr
ple sales in the next five years
and then you need a des
gner who, yes, we also had the t
am back then  a new person
has already been deployed who brings the know-how
to redefine these women's collections
and bring them up if
you think about it, the new collection is the
one that customers
will be shopping for in the next four weeks and we
're already promising ourselves a lot because
dina has it covered  now that it's younger
the modern thing that has the new
work clothes work clothes business
clothes it's more
casual so just full of it
before or or do you trust because
you say you're now open are a
fashionable person so that means you
before something somehow  really goes into series,
you look at it and say whoa,
I don't believe it, the kol  lesson
is currently hanging in the air and i think
i've been there since yesterday i think i've been
through the goal area six times
and always asked different people
why is that there why is that there
and why couldn't we still be
these are those are also a bit
stuck  so I'm extremely up to speed I
'm a product in marketing I'm
a sales person because I quite
simply believe that if the three elements are
well played
then the numbers will come automatically what what
do you think what can become of the company
in terms of value  the company is
currently three and a half billion
years ago it was somehow almost
twice that or so it goes like
this the potential is definitely
there i have also defined that the turnover can
actually double the market
value so i do believe that we
really have enormous potential  and that
's not the end of what you defined yourself for
in the next five years
, i think  be there it then goes on
and for me it's
set like that for five years what did you do so five years is
that made for you the positive
five years is
negative we have to be 60 ok so
yes you have to look at how you
feel but me  as I said it will then continue
afterwards with me or without
me okay who is the one who
disputes that the most that is
his old colleagues because with tommy
or how do you say who does that again
do they also nike you
maybe who in the sports area  and
yes i believe me i don't see it
hurting but i like competition you
always see when you can
learn from each other and and and not
interested but you can do
better and i'm interested in what you do with
what we always do for me  what was
good yesterday may not be
good enough today you have to keep
evolving the worst thing is when
you actually stand still and you have
you back shines but me
I'm interested every day in what makes crime thrillers even
better and there are
many who are doing well
but
don't know if someone has the same
potential as we do,
maybe a little bit here now,
but I just see something so enormous
growth the value is also in the brand
is already this tradition at so
it's been there for decades so you say
it has value or you say it
actually is but you can also
create a new brand within pa you
need it so no that already has  a verb
but you ca
n't rest on that heritage so not only but
if you have the value that we've been around for so
long and you think what's the
value no that's not it but
the relevance of the brand is ultimately
the value  not the heritage but
the relevance and we have i think
now we had we have the heritage
and we are now working on the
relevance so i think so  s the
value of the brand memory will increase,
but you don't do
anything that retro yet, but a lot of brands that
have been preserved use the
gamers a lot of such retro ideas, so of course
the sneaker companies anyway, but
I have the feeling there are  yes also such
luxury brands for jackets yes
outdoor area that play off very strongly so
Heritsch I
don't have the feeling with you yet like this
no that has it is so talk already
we already have this heritage from
think about it the skirt he has this
sweater worn in the roxy film with the
mouse
or we'll bring it again they're
this one second or memorial what
was that in the 80s at miami
vice or a
suit with the huge shoulder that of
course you've already given me ideas about how
we can revive it  so
we can still have parts with heritage
, so we have a kind of
led factory where we still have these parts in
there, that's unbelievable  what's
hanging in there from the old days it's so
nice but since you can actually
do it was recently sold
you thought reebok that's
actually such a cultural treasure shirts
and you can play out over the years
what it was like  yes yes
you can do that we will too but
one thing we have we still have so much
life in it and what
happens will be
okay okay so I'm very excited it
would be great so a global design
burns clearly Germany roots it
would all of us  it's good if it's
already you already have a
bit of an order with hugo boss
already have a bit of a stamp
to come from germany or
represent germany or don't feel it like
that so
germany is in swiss so why
but as an ambassador she has that
I already feel the responsibility is
clear to me and the pressure because of
course I have it on my shoulders and how
did a g  it says there are
three brands in germany that play a role
it's mercedes porsche and bus
and i said ok
yeah i've never seen it like that before but
somewhere it's still interesting so he
said a lot of foreigners when you talk about
brand worlds
german make in germany  then the three
powerhouses are named the most and now
i hope that i'm lucky
i have a great team behind me for sure
we have all the possibilities
here so don't call it
how should you say a one brand
you don't do we say that  a comeback
because out of sport and i'm
a keen athlete and i always say a
lot of athletes have had a comeback
and they were actually
even better after the comeback and i see
boss they were great once they've calmed down a
bit
and that's why  i
hope we can make a comeback soon
okay would be good for us well in the end everyone
knows well because the kardashians o  who
or something like that when you talk to people
that the german market is know that
everything is but from germany
he or are now as global fires
i think already from global burns
and we have to we have to be a
global berlin burns and not only
a german brand that's why we
have to internationalize ourselves that
's also how it's great that we
girls are great that we're a
german company but we have to become a
global brand that
definitely that's why even when
I see the testimonials i said  these
are global testimonials we can
not only take german testimonials
but you are your main working day is
here with your so from here
you do everything here yes i will be back to zurich on the weekend
which you can also find out in
switzerland but on
monday to  friday i'm basically
here or enough but that's so that
's the church
standing in front of walls as well as kendall  jenner comes
here to metzingen then
one is surprised it's
somehow not necessarily that between the
headquarters of a global at adidas
is sometimes the world and i don't
think that plays a role
in my example that's why this Krampus there
we obviously have to do a lot
but we have
here we have shops and we
have that so what you can do here
you obviously have
to create a world here on campus where people
say hey, at least the
area is beautiful you
can feel good there  well we also
said he is crazy from amsterdam
zurich to metzingen but efficient
finds it good the people are nice
i like it and the great hilfiger he
is also somehow
understood that you did it
he understood yes he understood it
it hurt a bit, but he
understood why I was doing it and
that it's still ok today, so we
definitely keep your fingers crossed it's
actually the hour now but
i
think thank you very much for letting us come
and in any case it's an exciting
story to follow that
yes that's all product marketing
out of a challenge but a great
challenge i'm convinced we'll get
through everything
thank you very much this podcast is
produced by popstars
at mr